while most big monster movies tend to
feature one or two giant beasts causing
mayhem and destruction Pacific Rim
showcased a host of spectacular
creatures from the moment Pacific Rim
was announced the idea always boiled
down to one thing
giant robots fighting giant monsters the
robots got a lot of attention but there
was no denying the appeal of the huge
creatures known as kaiju
kaijus are a race of amphibious
creatures genetically engineered by the
precursors a sentient race from the anti
vers they came to earth in 2013 and the
precursors open a portal between the
dimensions at the bottom of the Pacific
Ocean known as the breach allowing the
kaiju to enter Earth's dimension there
are about 15 Qaida's in total in the
Pacific Rim 1 and part 2 and out of
these 15 creatures we will select only
ten biggest kaiju based on weight
irrespective of category height or
length so let's take a look at these
creatures and number 10 we have Shrike
thorn
Shrek thorn is a category 4 kaijus that
appeared in Pacific Rim uprising and one
of three kaiju that attacks the city of
mega Tokyo in 2035 Shrek thoughts
skin is gray and barbed at the front of
his head shaped like a hammerhead shark
are multiple blue eyes other than its
ability to produce plasma that it can
use as an offensive weapon shrek thorn
carries sharp bioluminescent spines on
both of its tails
which can be launched becoming deadly
projectiles so regarding the size of the
skies you've given that it appeared in
the second movie we were kind of
expecting the cage to be bigger than the
ones from the first film but it is still
just on the number 10 spot according to
the official scale chart shrek thorn
stands a little over 300 feet and has a
weight of 2592 tons so at number 9 we
have muta for muta for is a category 4
kaijus appeared in the first film in the
year 2025 it manages to break through
the city's anti kaiju wall within one
hour of reaching it it enters the city
and proceed
to attack mutable has a hope shop curve
above its blatant and bori structure
around its head and coming down from its
chin in a crescent shape near the top of
millivolts blade crest is its mouth
merav or has three eyes on both sides of
its head in addition the creature
exhibits a bipedal structure containing
two large arms ending in large claws and
two very small almost insect-like
appendages on its chest similar to its
bladed head munivar
has a huge axe shaped structure
protruding from its back Mira Voss
rampage is short-lived however as
striker Eureka is immediately deployed
against it muta 4 is 28 feet taller than
leatherback at 295 feet tall or 89.9 2
meters and his weight is at 2630 tons so
going to number eight we have knife head
knife head is a category three kaiju
that emerged from the breach on February
29 20 20 it is a heavily built kaiju at
its most notable feature is its long and
brought sharp end it knows that could
easily cut through the armor of a Jaeger
atop the scent of its head resides a
blowhole that forcefully expels air just
like a whale whenever it resurfaces from
the water and has a large shell like
armor on its back while the rest of its
body is similar to that of a goblin
shark an appearance knife had possesses
two large dominant arms and two smaller
secondary arms protruding from its belly
its large arms each have three cloth
digits the middle digit being
significantly larger it also has a tail
with bright yellow lines running across
its body with the rest of its body being
dark grey in his eyes EJ is smart
however glowing blue the official scale
of knife head is 215 feet tall or 96
meters and weighs only 2,700 tons number
7
trespasser the first category 3 kg is at
number 7 on the list trespasser is the
first kaiju to emerge from the breech
and attack humanity in attacked San
Francisco on August 10 2013 and over the
course of 6 days
destroyed 3 Series in a 35 mile long
path of destruction before it was
finally killed by the United States
military
and the British Royal Air Force little
factual information could be a certain
from trespasser it stands taller or at a
level with the Golden Gate Bridge and is
strong enough to tear the structure
apart with his claws tresspasses skin
was thick and protective and could
withstand almost any type of
conventional weaponry trespasser emits
an orange bio luminous glow from its
sight its mouth like sladden knife head
and scanner trespassers main arms are
actually two fused arms each ending with
three cloth digits knife hat stands a
trainer and two feet tall or 92 meters
and has a weight of two thousand seven
hundred eighty tons number six
leatherback coming at number six spot on
the list is a category four kaiju
leatherback and naturally hostile
creature whose appearance it's like that
of a gorilla its movement resembles that
of a gorillas walking on his knuckles
with jumping abilities and not shovel
like hands it has six visible eyes and
an armored plated skin its thick skin
allows it to withstand great amounts of
damage without faltering pouncing on
enemies from behind leatherback uses the
weight of its opponent against them
however if injured leatherback uses
hit-and-run tactics to defeat foes it
will retreat from proactive battle and
hide until the enemy is distracted
leather bags main power move is a large
electromagnetic emission or EMP which
disables all electronics in a white
surrounding area a dangerous threat to
digitized villegas leatherback is
estimated to be 267 feet or 81 point
three eight meters tall and a weight of
two thousand nine hundred tons he was
killed in a battle of Hong Kong by [ __ ]
danger
number five scanner scanner is a
category 4 kaiju it protects the breach
from the jaegers alongside sladden and
ride u scanners appearance and behavior
as akin to that of a bull brought and
stocky its two curved horns jutting out
from its head act as a battering ram
against armored opponents like the
jaegers it's gonna possess four arms
that ate in its ability to move faster
than its opponent underwater it's plated
body armor allows it to take great
amounts of damage and the most severe
environments like most cars you it has a
green bio luminescent glow throughout
its body
it's a
to work in tandem with other kaiju makes
it a particularly dangerous foe in
combats like slamming trespasser and
knife head scanners primary arms are
actually two fused arms ending in
3-digit claws its height is 441 feet or
134 meters tall and a weight of only
three thousand two hundred and thirty
tons and a number four spot comes Ryan
Ryan is the first category five guide
you on the list and one of the three
kaiju that attacks the city of mega
Tokyo in 2035
Ryan is a bipedal kaiju likened to that
of a Tyrannosaurus Rex in either
appearance or temperance right in his
design with an inner and outer head
shaped like a Venus flytrap its inner
head is protected by the outer head a
heart shield like plates around his
skull the phosphorescent glow of its
blood is visible in the veins on the
surface of its face its veins glow when
it absorbs kinetic energy from attacks
Ryan can use the absorb energy - empower
itself or redirected towards an opponent
a category-5 guides you right in as the
largest and the deadliest of the three
Kaju that attacked mega Tokyo in 2035
its height is 350 feet or 100 6.8 metres
and weighing 3405 tons number three ride
you ride you is a category 4 kg and one
of the three kaiju who protected the
breach in January 12 2025 an aquatic
creature Reiji invokes a Galapagos
iguana and crocodile in appearance and
behavior brought shoulder ride to his
heavily armored along its back and head
the head itself is a tripartite jaw that
encases the creatures bioluminescent
head for projection its feet up bends
enabling it to swim quicker through the
water Reiji emerges from the breach
along with scanner and sladden to defend
it from [ __ ] danger and striker Eureka
when the jaegers arrived to bomb the
bridge he proceeds to stalk the jaegers
from the darkness during their approach
to the portal ride you assess Connor in
attacking [ __ ] danger tearing its right
arm from its body before [ __ ] danger
can kill scunner raiju s' height is
almost the same as Godzilla 2014 about
358 feet or 109 meters tall and weighing
3470
five tons number to flatten it was the
first category five ever encountered by
humanity during the events of Jared 12
2025 it was sent to protect the breach
from destruction the largest and
strongest of all the known kaijus Ladin
is unrivaled by any of its brethren in
battle
the creatures high toxicity level and
intelligence makes it the most lethal
kaiju in the pan-pacific defense corps
has ever faced sladden has take leathery
skin and three triple crown tails that
can be used for long-distance attacks of
piercing the arm of a Jaeger its tails
have enough power to rapidly spin and
lash out acting as a mid-range attack
even with a heavy amount of underwater
pressure working against them it also
has a spike like protrusion on his chest
which can extend forward and inflict
blunt damage on a Jaeger the sound of
slatterns roar can emit sound waves that
cause visible damage to the environment
in its situation
Saturn's height is estimated at 596 feet
and his weight is estimated at six
thousand seven hundred and fifty tons
its size strikes fear onto any foe and
number one spot can you guess yeah it's
the mega kaiju the mega kaiju is a
category 5 plus schedule - it has a
combined form or an amalgamation of
reijin Haku J and Shrek thorne merge
together by swarms of smaller robotic
hybrid kaiju it displays a few
attributes of its previous forms and
towers over the jaegers the mega kaiju
is a hexa pedal car with two tails that
have spear shape and similar to track
thongs the arm carapace of hakuta on his
two arms and for digitigrade legs and
strength on shoulders fused with
write-ins upper arm structure parts of
Ryan's head carapace appear below the
neck and the head is a fusion of all
three kaiju
with Haku just lower jaw separating two
two tusk horizons facial structure and
Shrek thorns upper head structure it has
ten eyes five on each side of its head
along its back are several jagged
carapace based spines and a casual spots
a color scheme similar to its kaiju
components as a fusion between the two
kaijus and ryan the mega kaiju is able
to use write-ins ability to redirect
kinetic and
gee it's size however is extremely big
it's four and 20 feet tall or 128 meters
and weighing over seven thousand eight
hundred and sixty-four tons making it
the biggest and the heaviest skies you
in the Pacific Rim universe so this
brings us to the end of the lists do
like share and subscribe for more videos
and do hit that notification bell